il y a ceux qui filment les flammes en
conduisant et les images sont
effroyablement spectaculaire et puis il
y a ceux qui courent tout en documentant
la menace qui gagne du terrain
le résultat est le même les feux
californien version 2010 9 sont toujours
aussi terrifiant ils sont des centaines
à combattre les flammes du feu baptisé
getty qui avale tout sur son passage
dans les banlieues cossues de la cité
des anges
dans certains quartiers des pompiers
soient dépassées exténué nous avons dû
faire des choix difficiles dit le chef
des pompiers de los angeles pour savoir
quel résidence on pouvait sauver ou pas
deux soirs comme de jour certains
tronçons de la fameuse autoroute 405 la
plus embouteillée du pays ont dû être
fermées
trop exposée aux flammes et à la fumée
dans certains quartiers des avis
d'évacuation obligatoire ont été émis
mais la consigne n'est pas toujours
respectée on veut voir les flammes qui
pourtant sont trop proches
d'ailleurs des élus ne sont pas tendres
l égard des récalcitrants
si vous regardez le feu vous êtes idiots
allez vous en
dans le comté de sonoma au nord de los
angeles
après cinq jours de lutte contre le feu
de cannes qu'eads les efforts des
pompiers sont récompensés mais dans le
sillon de ce feu les dégâts ont été
considérables
il ne reste plus grand-chose de
résidence comme celle ci elle a été
rasée par les flammes
ce fermier lui s'en tire plutôt bien
il a failli tout perdre mais le travail
des pompiers a limité les dégâts
le gouverneur de la californie n'a
d'ailleurs que de bons mots pour ses
soldats du feu oui 20 heures seulement
dit il ils ont réussi à éteindre 330
incendie le maire de los angeles
constate que l'ampleur des feux est
importante certes mais la croissance est
un peu plus lente
en tout cas pour l'instant car les
fameux vent chaud de santana sont
attendus mercredi
il pourrait alors alimenter les brasiers
et donner du fil à retordre aux pompiers
en attendant selon leur localisation des
californiens sont les témoins des images
aux couleurs de fin du monde alors que
d'autres voient poindre un peu d'espoir
face aux flammes dévastatrices ici
frédéric arnould radio canada montréal